Matt Welch with my co-author Nick  Gillespie on ask a libertarian day next  question comes via facebook from Jameson  pen can a libertarian small-l  realistically hold his head up high  while working for that I abital LOL  either directly or as a consultant yes  emphatically so I started out working as  a lifeguard in a library page for in  Middletown New Jersey I was an umpire  for the city of Lakeland there you go on  track and you know to to suggest that  because you're part of the system you  can't criticize it would be like saying  hey you know sitting Bull we're giving  you this free land on a reservation so  shut the hell up you bet your sweet  bippy you can and nobody should be can  nobody should be complaining or  criticizing or analyzing government more  than the people who work in it or work  for it